any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from the magic
okay frank the final three questions i'm
going to do
uh now each final question seems to me
i haven't started don't worry these are
quick these are as long as you want them
to be
uh but uh but to hear frank's answer i'm
going to ask you to sign up for my
newsletter briankeating.com
uh to hear if you want to hear frank's
answer because i'm trying to get uh more
engagement with my
beloved audience we got 10 000 people
out there that are on the mailing list
and another 20 000 or so on itunes and
youtube so i do enjoy it i do want more
people
so i want to be able to have a direct
channel so if you want to hear frank's
answers to the last three questions
you'll have to sign up for my newsletter
at bryantkeating.com
you'll get life lessons from frank from
jim simons from many other
people both at mit or elsewhere
okay frank are you ready to go into the
impossible okay so last time i asked you
the question the first question involves
what's called your ethical will
and actually someone who you know very
well or know of
alfred nobel his will was not just a
material will
it not only contain what he wanted and
done with his money he had no children
no spouse
no heirs directly and so he gave his
money
in part to an ethical cause which was as
you know to improve
to the benefit of all mankind or as we
say now humankind
i want to ask you in your ethical will
when you reach the biblical age of 120
and you're uh you know you go in the
night uh very peacefully at that ripe
old age
uh what do you want to bequeath to
humanity
your biological heirs uh your grandson
but also to
ideological errors oh god
you promised me you'd answer it last
time
i have thought about this a little bit
but not
too much not not maybe not enough
uh yet but uh the
well first of all i'm sort of
operationally answering the question
uh as as i go on i i'm
i have a my body of work i think is my
uh is is that so
it it uh it includes of course technical
papers but i also think now
uh especially with fundamentals actually
i'm starting to
to have a uh
a legacy that that will be a broader
cultural legacy
and so that that's that's so
work my you know my of course i have my
uh
my family and they they they know me
very well
so they'll have more concrete memories
uh and i want to you know enrich
enrich their lives and i have a
wide body of friends all over the world
now
and some institutions
in shanghai and and stockholm that
uh i've been influential in helping to
to
grow and start and develop so yeah i'd
like to see those thrive
uh
uh i'm right well part of the cultural
the the cultural legacy is uh
is may grow in different directions i'm
writing a mystery novel now
that we'll touch on some philosophical
issues too
wow you promised to come back for that
too okay frank
yes
so and you know in in my i'm i may
you know these these are maybe not as
grand i'm thinking about um you know i
do write these wall street journal
columns
i'm thinking about putting them together
in an augmented form
for a kind of uh complement
to fundamentals which just goes off in
different directions and
comments and
the opposite direction not drilling down
but opening up
to a
cultural and scientific applications
that are
not necessarily fundamental but but all
over the place and
wow so so
those are some of the things and you
know if the opportunity arises this
seems far-fetched but
if at the moment but if the opportunity
arises
to in connection with
climate change or control of nuclear
weapons or
addressing the challenges of artificial
intelligence getting
to be our uh peers so to speak
uh i'd be happy to try to
help it contribute to clarify and bring
some wisdom
to those questions well there's a person
i can introduce you to
at your university named max tag mark
who's also interested in those very same
topics
you beavers may save the world yet but i
might get the stuff beaver yeah as you
know
okay um second to last question is
uh is going into the future as well
which relates to arthur c clarke's
monolith in 2001 a space odyssey
and uh it's basically this object that
some civilization put
on earth and on the moon but meant to be
discovered when humanity was mature
enough maybe to decipher it
and it kind of reminds me of one of your
here was it on oh
on earth in the in the prehistoric times
yeah yeah so the opening scene has a
has a clip of them um moving around yeah
hominins hitting it with the bone but oh
yeah
oh i i i i know that very very well yeah
i've seen it
so it reminds me of the times i think i
love that yeah me too
um it reminded me a little bit of um of
one of your heroes richard feynman
who had this cataclysm question and
somebody asked him if in some cataclysm
all scientific knowledge were to be
destroyed and only one sentence passed
on to the next generation of creatures
what would it be so i want to ask you if
you had a monolith that would last for a
billion years or more
what would you put on it or in it what
what i'd put
well i think we may have discussed it
earlier
or maybe i'm confusing it with another
podcast but as i said
our core theory or standard model is
something you can uh
and capsule encapsulate in a short
computer program
okay so i would put that on a usb stick
and that would be
not a cd-rom not a not an eight-track
okay good
all right the last question uh involves
arthur c clarke's laws
uh you already quoted the one we opened
the podcast with which is any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
yet another law for every expert there's
an equal and opposite
expert and is the final law that we
describe as the name of this podcast is
the only way
to discover the limits of the possible
is to venture beyond them
into the impossible and that's the
that's the name of our podcast
so i want to ask you frank what yeah as
a 20 year old 30 year old 40 year old
however
what piece of advice would you give if
this mysterious time traveler
called frank wilcheck encountered a
young frank wilchuk what piece of advice
would you tell
him to kind of give him the courage to
go into the impossible
well i'd say read fundamentals first of
all
second uh
oh gosh uh i
i i'd say um
i'm not sure what the free i'm sure i
understand the framing of this question
properly
but uh
i'd say maybe the advice i would give if
i could somehow is that uh
to it to it to a teenager uh
life seems to be happening very fast
and uh you know i remember when i was in
this
when i was growing up people used to say
uh don't trust anybody over 30
or like the who sang uh hope i die
before i get old
right which by the way they haven't of
course yeah
the thing is that you
it's you shouldn't feel guilty about
exploring
and uh invest
investing in exploration as opposed to
trying to immediately exploit the things
you've learned
and and the skills you have uh
is a very wise thing to do
so uh explore before you
dig so to speak or while you're digging
explore
uh also that that's because life is not
so short
there's there's there's plenty of time
to think a lot of things
well that's beautiful frank and it's
more important
more important to get your choices right
and find something you love then to uh
you know start making money or
getting tenure or whatever it is just
think about what you're doing before you
do it
yeah very good i'm learning to become a
flight instructor
uh on my spare time which is not very
much but you know one thing i'll say to
my students
is you know if you look at the moon the
moon is only a half a degree wide on the
sky that means if you're off by
15 arc minutes you'll miss the moon
completely
right so you got to be very careful
anyway frank i want to thank you for
many things for being
an inspiration to many of us in the
world both in the sciences and outside
of the sciences
this book is a is a gateway drug into
the mind
of frank wilcek uh it is uh is a book
full of meaning
and actually you know the laws of
physics describe
what the world is but uh but i think the
way that you look at it
gives gives a sort of prose but infused
with
with the way a scientist should look at
the world and i found it very beautiful
very moving
almost emotional at some points and and
i want to thank you for being
vulnerable and and and and also
courageous
as i know you always are so thank you
for sharing so much of your time
good luck with the book thank you and
we'll talk to you again soon when you're
when your murder mystery comes out till
next time yeah until next time i hope
this isn't
i'm sure there'll be many next time okay
it's a joy thank you for having me
bye bye any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic